I'm sure things are taking you over your
head for what you can do with this okay
the whole point of this is to think
about okay I can't actually put in x
equals one interview can i I can't just
go there and tell me where it is unlike
here where you camilli like the reason
why you get two is because if you put 0
in to you true just pops out but as you
keep you can see you can't always put in
the value and you can swap approach
something so for instance here what
would I do this numerator I can
factorize right but limit as X
approaches 1 of X plus okay so because I
can see here right from the first line
that X is not actually defined the
function is not defined at x equals 1 I
can disregard x equals 1 x cut yeah X
can't be equal to 1 right that first
line tells me there's a restriction okay
so therefore this guy I can cancel right
these two can disappear okay they can be
taken out of the factor so I'm getting
this now the point where actually can
just like here I can pop in the value
that I'm trying to approach right as X
approaches 1 this thing is going to
become closer and closer to 1 plus 1
right which is 2 okay
so therefore what does that actually
mean well let's let's graph these things
directly let's even think back to when
we were talking about if leg asymptotes
returning that polynomial division and
so on right degree 2 divided by degree 1
what result that you expect you degree 1
right it's going to be a straight line
it's a linear function in fact it's this
linear function with one crucial
difference right do not do this right
thanks respond
yeah I did where is X equal 1 x equals 1
there's my intercept X equals 1 is
already here right so there's some point
over here where just like we said from
the very first line the graph is not
actually defined there's a little tiny
infinitesimally small hole there right
you can't put an execute one so there's
a whole new circle right but it doesn't
mean like I can still approach that
value I could approach in her involve I
could approach it from below and sure
enough I'm getting closer to 2 I'm dick
closer and closer because I can get as
close as I like I just can't get to
itself right because I can't actually
put in 1 right so therefore this idea
here of a perche limit even though I
can't actually evaluate it
that's why I limits are valuable ok I
can actually evaluate something that I
can't evaluate I can see what it's
approaching even if I can actually get
there ok so now I'm going to give you my
formal definition north of mine it's a
it's a well-known definition and I'm
going to put right on the definition
yes people could watch me girls having
this ring through their pencil if you
want for reference I'm giving you
basically a kind of rewording of what's
on page 268 of your textbook they give
you a definition Beverly I'm a huge fan
of ever that's okay so he comes he comes
okay yep so he comes my definition it's
it's formal which is why I'm using all
this notation and that's why I'm putting
it with the other one right okay if I
say if I say the limit as X approaches
some number for this function if I say
that that limit is B that means I can
pick some value of x such that I can get
arbitrarily close too big okay let me
write that out and then we'll unpack it
okay means we can substitute some value
into that function and get arbitrarily
close
- so for example let's think about this
guy here let's think about this thank
you okay
this limit is - and the reason why is
because if you want to say get how close
would you like to get to - you're like
I'd like to get within point 1 of that
of that spot there okay so you wanna get
to me then point 1 of 2 I can do that I
can find an x value that'll do that all
I have to do is say ok 0.1 equals that
thing and then I'll solve and then the
solution to that it'll be like you know
you might get one point zero one or 0.99
okay so you have an x value that will
get you within point one up there okay I
should have said two point one that's
where I want to go with the ending point
one of that exit point yeah I know no I
don't want to put one that's really far
away actually in terms of my accuracy of
measurement I want to get within point
zero zero one or within point zero zero
zero zero one or they have this some
they call they call this song in in full
tolerance they call this Seamas so for
example if you want something to be
99.99999% certain they call that sigma
570 okay so that means I would have to
be within zero point zero zero zero zero
zero - I guess that's like that's how
course I would be to be 99.999% certain
okay well guess what there's an X value
you can pick that will get you that
close to two and because you can get as
close as you like we say that's what the
limit is okay
if for example I can't actually get that
close it's somewhere earlier I have to
stop there's that earlier place you have
to stop that's the real limit okay
in this case I can get as close to 2 as
I like over here I can get as close to
zero as I like for example your life
tell me tell me is there a place on this
function where I'm going to be equal to
your point here is yours
one and the actress yes there is you
just need to go far enough you'll find
it it's dead right and if you want to
add more zeroes you can do that too you
just have to go further okay so this is
the limit if you can find some values
such that when you put it in you'll get
however close you want to be so that
actual value okay like I said I prefer
to say it's just the value that you
approach because that's just a much more
common sense of way of saying yeah but
later on as you'll see it's like well
you know what over here sorry over I've
upped it up over here right this is y
equals x plus two right you're not
actually approaching - you actually get
there don't you right I do more than
just approached I like in an asymptote
right I can actually get that value
which is why this thing I put a box
around is more intuitive but in terms of
like a rigorous formal definition it
kind of doesn't hold on as much water as
the other one